each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so hi everyone a script pleasure to
welcome dr run a horse who i say vp of
business development in a bay area
start-up got better spell controls and
they've been doing some interesting work
in controlling data center environmental
conditions using sensor networks beta
based on sensor networks and today is
here to talk about the projects they're
doing and some of the results that they
got welcome okay thank you and i want to
try to make this as interactive as
possible today so hopefully you guys can
get something out of this and learn
something a little bit about what we're
doing so since we're a small group maybe
do you want to quickly go around and
introduce yourself and maybe what you
want to get out of today just so i have
a little idea of what you guys are
interested in glory
great to meet you sure great
symbol for jewelry okay great
I'm Garrett you're ever on the dct nut
butter cookie okay perfect Victoria
D I are actually the highest
mighty microsoft wireless architect for
all of our Wi-Fi staff on campus and I'm
interested in seeing if you're using
Wi-Fi or zigbee or some other type of
technology and how if you've done both
of those if you tie those together okay
yeah we'll talk about that recent
that looking somewhere
okay bender with 20 great okay okay and
I think there might be some people
online welcome so again my name is jeff
brown horse with federal controls just a
little background on myself i have a
chemical engineering degree and I worked
for Honeywell in the process control
group for several years implementing IT
systems to run large farm on biotech
companies so I kind of have a very IT
centric background I have an MBA from
the UC Berkeley School of Business and
joined federal controls last summer so
federal control is just a little
background is is a company that's
focused on energy management and saving
our customers energy we were started in
2004 really focused on the the building
market specifically older buildings and
our founder cliff Feder spiel came out
of UC Berkeley where they had been doing
a lot of research into wireless sensor
networks and where a lot of the core
wireless sensor network technology came
out of so he really adapted their
technology I the University and brought
it to the commercial building market our
founder also has a PhD from MIT in the
intersection between artificial
intelligence and HVAC controls so he has
a very unique background which is kind
of appropriate for what we're doing
we've been in both the building in data
center market for a while hopefully
today I can kind of tell you a little
bit about what we're doing around using
wireless sensor network data to drive
environmental control specifically
within data center so feel free to stop
me if you have any questions hopefully
we can make this pretty interactive I
some of these slides I mean we kind of
all know some of the problems in data
centers first you know server
manufacturers an ashtray specify that we
should measure the inlet air going the
servers but very few people do it
Microsoft is clearly in the lead and in
its deployment of actually measuring
inlet air temperatures you know the
controls piece too even if you're
measuring the inlet air typically your
control system isn't controlled with
inlet air it's usually controlled by
return air coming back to the crack
units in the data center or by supplier
but both ways of controlling really
don't have any idea of what's going on
with your actual servers so you know
there's clearly a lot of inefficiency
and hotspots and other thermal issues
that that crop up so it takes a you know
large deployments really understand your
thermal environment but then when you
actually begin to approach the control
problem of what's happening in data
centers it's a very difficult problem
first of all as you know data centers
tend to be open plan so they're quite
large open areas there's not the areas
of influence are quite wide so one
cooling unit can affect a lot of
different units it's very hard to divide
up or is the call zone a data center to
control temperatures so there's there's
a big challenge with this kind of open
plan control when you build your HVAC
systems and data centers you want them
or done then if one unit fails your so
if you don't want your whole data center
to go down but with that redundancy
comes a lot of complexity you know how
do you if you have redundant units how
to use them appropriately when do you
use them and there are some big
challenges too with fighting I mean
hopefully you guys don't have in your
data center but I've walked in somewhere
we see two units literally four feet
away from each other and once you minify
and the others dehumidified we've seen
some heating which they should never do
in any data center so the coordination
of cooling and data centers is a huge
problem and that's it's not very well
done from what we've seen a lot of data
centers and hopefully Microsoft is ahead
of the curve
you guys are fortunate enough to have a
lot of PhDs on staff and they probably
are helping you with your data center
cooling control not everybody's is that
lucky and it's very hard to have one
full-time so you know as we say we like
to we package a PhD and put it in a box
so around some intelligent cooling
control so you know there's big problems
on both you know the measuring side and
also the control side and data centers
and what we've seen is surprisingly data
center cooling control typically is
worse than say a building like this you
know they monitor the brooms and have a
pretty good understanding of how the
rooms work but in data centers we
control paradigm is is quite weak so I
this is what we do so we have a frat to
LF toilet left it on out in the car but
we have our own wireless sensor modules
and we'll talk a little bit more
detailed exactly what they are this is
what they look like our model is that we
actually run to thermistors straight off
then we put this on the top of a rack
and run it down and measure the top and
bottom of a rack that really provides us
the insight into the thermal environment
the data center what we do with that
then is a bunch of analysis to really
understand you know the simple things
like excuse me where are your hot spots
and you know where where are some of the
issues but really that data allows us to
as you've probably seen CFD modeling or
computational fluid dynamics modeling
kind of has a picture of the air flow
within a data center we're able to take
all our data from our center network and
build a statistical CFD model basically
in our software that is dynamic and
changes depending on your environment
you take a take out a couple racks you
put in a couple racks or even during the
day as you know I I don't know somebody
a server farm serving up videos you know
gets really active when all the high
school kids come home we can dynamically
model that and then that what allows us
to do is actually begin to control your
cooling units and coordinate them to
match your cooling capacity with your IT
load and yeah the sales e thing is we
typically can show an ROI of less than
two years so how do we do this well you
can see a very ugly rack of one of our
customers hopefully yours are all look
much better but we typically put our
module at the top running you know
thermistors down yeah you guys have a
little different way of doing it which
is which is fine and you know this is
deployed across you know we're just
measuring inlet air going into servers
and usually deployed every kind of four
to five racks but depending on the
particular customer site so we deploy
these and this collects our data you
know it this technology is a wireless
mesh networking technology so its
simplest ways to say it's a zigbee like
again I think the next slide will go
into a little bit more the details so
you know there's a mesh network that
that is formed and you know pretty
pictures and but the key thing is all
this data then we use to feed into
basically this intelligent algorithm
that dynamically controls cooling sorry
what's the date at you
data you you how much needed oh the
samples you need or yes you got John
packets oh so that's a good question to
the technology is based on if you were
to dust networks we use dust network
radios so there you know they make their
you know mesh networking radio it's a
line with the wireless heart standard so
it's not not zigbee they are incredibly
robust their main customers use them and
places like oil refineries and heavy
industry so we get close like 99.9 or
something of that level of reliability
of a packets it's a time-synchronized
protocol so it's not collision based so
so we get very good reliability of our
data set yeah it's typically a minute to
two minutes it's configurable but yeah
usually our customers are doing a minute
to two minutes yeah what do you
interviewed for TV movies with like an
Ethernet back in order another wireless
network and I didn't put that in there
so our wireless sensors talked to a
gateway which is then plugged into
ethernet yeah so typical gateway can
support about 256 which ones are 55
sensors it's the 900 megahertz a
licensed spectrum
yep controls the temperature how far
back does it take of samples I mean
doesn't just take the most recent
readings from temperature sensors
determine what the next temperature
should be right right so i think that
the simple answer is well kind of both
it uses historical data to build up a
model and does things like perturb a
system right turn down a crack in it
just a little bit and see how the whole
system responds to develop its internal
model so it's using a lot of the history
data to you know determine basically you
know be able to answer questions like if
this rack gets hot which cooling unit
should I turn up and down but then it's
also using real-time data to see how
that model adjusts over time but this is
supposed to be a picture of a wireless
mesh network but you guys I think
probably all know how that works yeah so
a little bit more on the technology
piece it is all battery-powered the dust
radios are incredibly powerful so we get
three to ten years of battery life and
you know we can monitor that battery
life and show you how many months left
you have on the batteries so time
synchronized protocol there's about
three layers of security so it's a kind
of a pseudo-random frequency hopping
which which is kind of a security
measure in itself it's got encryption
and keys and a couple other security
features built into it we found it's
incredibly robust and reliable both in
data centers as well as we deploy these
a lot of buildings with concrete rebar
which tend to be very tough RF
environment so it works very well with
cordless phones down
and it's smart enough that if it does
hit a channel of interference it'll just
stop using that so again very robust yet
bless your backhand and yes so it's a
good question i don't know the exact
answer but i think it's you know less
than a minute or two so if we're getting
a sample rate of say a minute you know
to get it back to the controls it might
be a couple seconds and then usually
within a minute it should make a you
know control decision based on that what
is the largest bully never sink with the
thing single base station
I'll see how many wars so it can support
255 I think we've we typically are a
little conservative so we typically put
in like maybe 170 at a time it actually
supports longer battery life because you
have less nodes that are both routing
and sending signals but yeah so I mean
we've done 170 pretty easily let's see
as far as yeah so I mean dust networks
is our supplier you know we're not a
wireless sensor company we don't make
firmware or program you know if you
really want to learn more about the
technology you know dust networks there
they've been a great partner to work
with and pretty robust technology so our
solution is entirely web-based so from
our architecture sense perspective you
deploy wireless temperature sensors it
talks to a base station which then the
ethernet is connected to a server that
runs our control algorithms and that
server then can control crack units
directly we have a wireless control
module as well that has actually picture
yeah so it actually has outputs so we
can directly plug into variable
frequency drives on the control units
around the cooling units or chilled
water valves or both to directly control
the units if and a lot of our customers
have pretty basic data centers and the
cooling units are standalone so we can
directly control them so we do both the
sensing and the control piece wirelessly
yep yep yeah it's wireless it has a zero
to 10 volt output so it can talk to just
about anything yeah so if we have a zero
to 10 volt you know if you have to
double a's it's only 3 volts so we have
to power that and but typically if
you're plugging in the variable
frequency drive it has power right there
so most devices you talk 0 to 10 volts
to has power so we just pulled from
their batteries act as a backup the
other piece that we do is there's
building management systems BMS azure
building automation systems in your data
centers so we can speak and communicate
with those systems so bacnet is an open
protocol that's used to communicate to
building management systems we can
communicate the BMS is and then control
set points and cooling units through
that typically more sophisticated
customers already have their coin units
networked together and then we just pass
through their systems so they can use
the same interface they can do manual
overrides of our control if if they
desire so and then we also do analog
integration we can plug directly into a
control panel and send them an analog
signal so we can really we can also do
web services you know xml interface so
it bc interfaces our system really can
bridge the gap between IT and facilities
which is kind of a challenge in the
space yeah so it if you're from a
facility side you know our software is
kind of like a superb
already control so we sit on top of your
just in control and do energy efficiency
have you guys looked at demand response
at all in your data centers demand
respond to you familiar with that you
know during the hottest days in the
summer you turn down your energy usage
and get paid by the local utilities
instead of turning right right so our
software enables some of the demand
response capabilities to for both
buildings and data centers so there we
go we asked question about the control
technology I mean here's a little bit
while high level on a slide back and I
can talk to a little bit more you know
the system is is really designed to
solve a very difficult problem when you
deploy sensor networks you get hundreds
and thousands of or tens of thousands or
probably even more in your case data
points and within a data center and you
get lots of data but you know saying I
don't know of 50,000 square foot data
center you'll probably have what about
40 cooling units roughly so you have
this problem where you have thousands of
points controlling a few points you know
30 40 50 points so that that's a that's
a very difficult control problem and
that's basically what we have solved and
we can handle you know lots of points
we're waiting for the day when servers
with their internal temperature probes
actually finally get to communicate out
to the rest of the world I'm not sure if
you guys have looked at that but you
know most server manufacturers have a
temperature probe usually somewhere
between four to six inches inside the
intake into a server and so there's some
interfaces like company called Richard
Zeta as an interface unit tell us there
I PMI interface once we can pull out
that data will have even more
temperature readings but our algorithm
kind of does some
advanced control to really understand
you know how all these points really can
drive you know 30 or 40 points and
that's what we've solved and it's
intelligent the sense that it you know
it actually learns it has you know a lot
of artificial intelligence built into it
and it can adapt I think a big challenge
in you know a lot of colo facilities
we've talked to was customers take racks
in and out and the load is actually
quite dynamic both from the number of
servers and also the output of the
servers right because you know
datacenter server just typically doesn't
always you know run at eighty percent
utilization all the time we would love
it if that was the case but load really
shifts over the course of the day and
we've seen our system you know for one
particular customer at you know seven
thirty in the morning whole data center
basically wakes up with the rest of the
company so it can dynamically respond to
that and then it really has the ability
to determine which cooling unit which
Kraw or crack influences which server
and how that changes over time and if
you've been in data centers you know
with under air floors there's cabling
and in all sorts of stuff underneath
that you know can change over time you
pull run a bunch of network cables and
so the environment changes and it's you
know very tough to model you know from a
point in time so our system kind of
dynamically corrects for those type of
things
right they I models yeah so that's
probably about all I can say right now
you know all of this technology is
patent pending that we're developing and
uh yeah that's kind of our secret sauce
increase the cooling or do you actually
try to like proactively predict what
will happen right that's a great
question right now it is is reactive and
you know we've developed this quorum
control model that works but clearly in
the future we are going to develop a
more reactive and predictive capability
and especially as we begin to have more
customers interested in demand response
you know if we can tell it's going to be
at you know incredibly hot day today you
know we can do some pre cooling or
depending on your HVAC system but yeah
and make sure you know the data center
is cool you know a couple minutes before
all the servers typically go up at you
know 730 or some backup algorithm runs
at you know three o'clock in the morning
on a regular basis yeah so we're not
there yet but it's definitely direction
we're heading I won't talk to this much
because I'm sure you've had the same
experience that deploying these sensor
networks adds a lot of value to begin to
see where their issues in your data
center and you know gives you an insight
for your facilities people that they've
never had before and there's a huge
value in that and you know we talk to
our customers and say we recommend that
first and a coupled with our system you
can get energy savings right away but
then then you can really look at some of
the other best practices out there
especially around cooling whether it's
hot or cold aisle containment you know
making sure all your holes are plugged
in your under air floor distribution you
you know blanking all this stuff
having a system in that gives you a lot
of data is really a good first step and
it sounds like you guys are doing this
so then it really we like why we like
this wireless sensor module approach is
that we call kind of our service we
provide persistent commissioning but it
allows customers to really can make sure
your data center is always running
optimally you know over time and you
know we know that I mean I've seen data
centers that are put up and they're
working perfect on day one and then you
know day a hundred they're already kind
of out of whack so you really get real
time feedback and what's happening this
is kind of an interesting inside I'm not
sure if you guys are run into this but
this is always kind of fascinating uh so
a lot of wrecks have doors on them right
in there you know 95% perforated and you
know most people say oh that's fine and
there's lots of studies saying it
doesn't affect air flow but we've seen
this is you know one instance we act you
know where there was over a 10-degree
drop by just opening the front and back
doors and we're actually working in a
cluster customers cloud cluster they had
about what four rows of you know 15
racks of you know brand new servers
running a cloud instance you know all
new gear i think it was IBM you know
both equipment and racks and their doors
you know we're brand new there was a 19
degree temperature difference inside you
know that where the inlet where the air
is going into the server when the door
was open and closed and this was you
know fully loaded you know they're
blanking panels it's kind of everything
that you'd expect but I think what we
think is that the door provides just
enough back pressure that any of these
little holes can get the air the hot air
flowing backwards you know coming from
the outlet just because that a little
bit of back pressure makes it easier for
the air to come to the front and side
going out the back so you've probably
seen results like this
deploying your systems but you know we
see that's that's a big benefit and so
our little side campaign is take off
your doors I and of course you know what
I more important than the me talking you
know here's a couple case studies for
customers of what we've been able to
achieve with our system so this is the
state of California Franchise Tax Board
which the News Center is quite busy
right now is all their tax filings go
through there so this was a pilot
project for us that we did with Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab and so there right
now verifying all our numbers and making
sure they're accurate so this was you
know a small data center 10,000 square
feet with 12 liebherr chilled water
cooling units they had built it out
about sixty percent and then virtualized
it and so they brought it down to about
forty percent capacity but what was
interesting is the cooling units were
all on all the time their operators had
tried to turn off a couple but kept on
getting hot spots just so they were
never comfortable trying to turn it down
you know we put in it was only yeah so
it's 25 wireless sensor modules
measuring 50 points so you know not not
a very data dense deployment but you
know it was sufficient we typically you
know implemented on the outside of the
rows just where typically are the
hottest temperatures out of the we
installed variable frequency drives on
four of the twelve cooling units
typically there are the ones closest to
the racks and we did some rearrangement
of tiles and you know reset some of the
set points of the cooling units and what
our implementation was is controlling
these for VFDs and then the remaining
eight we would turn on and off as
necessary right so each implantation
slightly different in this particular
one they were liebert vfds so they have
this retrofit kit so we were sending
commands the libra units through their
site link gateway protocol which were
resetting the set points so basically
for return air because they were
controlling off return air so we didn't
touch that new a return there right and
shoot yeah so the the local liebert unit
in this case actually controlled the VFD
speed in the chilled water valve
according to its own controls but we
were changing their set point so you
know that was the feedback loop we use
for that system other instances we have
basically made the libra units kind of
dumb cooling coils where we actually
control the BFD and the chilled water
valve independently again it's just
depending on the customer and then for
the other eight units we turn them on
and off because they only had one speed
and as well as adjusting their set
points to adjust their chilled water
valve position so what was interesting
is at any given time typically six to a
to the units were turned off by our
system and which ones were turn off kind
of depended on the conditions of the
servers Wow of course maintaining all
the temperatures within ashtray limits I
think what was interesting is where you
get some kind of counterintuitive
behavior that we didn't even expect is
that most of the servers were clustered
on kind of one side of the data center
and what happened is the VFDs were next
to those servers so they were typically
on but at lower speed the cone units in
the middle of the data center were off
but there was to be one that was
farthest away from the servers that was
on which seems very counterintuitive at
first kind of our analysis seems to
imply that it was basically providing
back pressure so
the cool air coming from the cooling
units next to the servers may stayed
there and this just provided some back
pressure and which crack unit was on or
off varied over time based on load so
that's kind of the behavior get with
some of this dynamic cooling control you
know with a 10,000 square foot data
center you know we were state still able
to get some pretty significant energy
savings you know primarily from fan
savings but also from some chilled water
savings to put it concentrated into a
small number of servers before you want
to spread it across many servers to make
the cooling unit most efficient you know
that's an interesting question I mean
I'm not sure if I'm qualified to you
know fully answer that but I think one
of the things that we've seen and the
next case study will kind of show it is
that if you have a more heavily loaded
data center it's actually better to keep
all your units on but turn them down to
say like eighty percent then you know
have you know eighty percent of them on
at full blast and you know twenty
percent off
Oh
okay so they were running all the time
anyways to make any sense to try at that
variable speed we wouldn't get any cost
at Fulton right right yeah yeah what's
interesting is so if you turn down a VFD
eighty percent you get about or turn it
down twenty percent you get about fifty
percent energy savings because there's a
cube law relationship between the fan
speed and power so by turning you know
by turning down all your crack units
eighty percent you'll get more energy
savings then turning off twenty percent
of them yeah yeah so I mean heavily
loaded data centers you know there are
you know there's a little less bang for
your buck but I think where the
opportunity is is using your right
full service now to purchase another
Jepsen our days decommissioning
yeah and in heavily yeah and heavily
loaded data centers there's still an
opportunity for VFDs you know if you're
able to use your wireless sensor network
to control hopefully you'll slightly
lower your cooling required and then you
can load up your data center more and
you get higher densities you know safely
so there's still an opportunity to get
some excess capacity out of your
existing facilities with this type of
infrastructure yeah you can see this is
when we turned it on this is they they
had a bunch of alarms based on relative
humidity and if you raise your
temperature your relative humidity goes
down so they had to turn on their
humidifiers for a little while to get
their relative humidity back up which is
kind of an interesting story of how much
energy humidity humidification actually
uses yeah sure so so in the case week
you have a data center and let's say you
know half your machines are heavily
loaded and half of them are running
pretty much an idol is it best to have a
heavily
loaded containers very condensed and try
to cool this just those or spread the
heavily bit of that heavy load across a
wide number of spread the heavily loaded
machines across your physical data
center so you have more studies in
between em right so again I'm not the
expert but if you had variable frequency
drives installed it would probably make
sense to spread that load across your
data center and then your risk of hot
spots is also decreased if you don't it
might make sense to where there is
excess cooling capacity put your load
and kind of do a little bit more of
matching of IT load if physically with
your cooling load yeah so fifty-eight
percent fan reduction you know this is
over thirteen percent of your total IT
or your total data centers usage I you
start getting some big numbers yeah to
savings from changing the front
right do you have anything how to affect
Denver's resolution because this is
based on what you're basing your control
decision right right track you're
getting a super guy you sure you're
trying to enforce a better one and this
how you get these name savings so to get
really much better and even the
temperature so that's a good question i
don't i don't have I don't exactly know
I know that we've been able to in all
these instances get these energy savings
while making sure the temperature
readings we're getting were within
ashtray limits so I should have that
information that would be good to know
and I I'm sure someone from our team can
run that analysis here's another data
center again it's it's quite small this
was you know for a large software
company in the bay area that they wanted
kind of a pilot to see how our system
works so again you know kind of small I
think there what's interesting is that
so it's 5,000 square feet six cross so
chilled water liebert units but our
implementation was slightly different we
installed yet six VFDs and we directly
controlled the VFDs they didn't have a
building management system or anything
so we were actually controlling them
directly and you know again pretty
pretty small but we deployed measuring
48 temperature points they had gone
through an audit with a local
engineering firm of all the different
best practices they could roll out their
data center it was about half hot out
cold I'll it was kind of a mess it was
kind of a lab facility you know they had
a bunch of holes and their their floor
you know they could have done
containment you know done a hot air
return platinum in the ceiling but they
chose to do nothing of that and
implemented our system first just to
kind of kind of see and yeah so all this
stuff goes in quickly so what was
interesting is the energy savings
they're able to achieve we're equal to
what they predicted with with all of the
the various energy efficiency measures
if they were implemented so you know
basically they their data center had a
lot more cooling than it was needed so
we're able to turn down the fans to
about fifty percent most of the time so
we get about eighty percent fan energy
savings and you know pretty large energy
savings it was interesting I was in
there when when they turned it on and
it's amazing how quiet the data center
God does the faint you know the fans the
in the units and even the UPS units you
know the buzz of them what went down a
little bit as the IT load went down so
you know this is again where we were
directly controlling chilled water valve
position and fan speed so I mean that's
kind of an overview of what we do I was
it wasn't sure exactly how this would
work but it'd be curious to hear a
little bit of feedback now that you've
kind of heard a little bit of what we're
doing more on the control side you know
how would this fit in into your
deployment of wireless sensors have you
started I think last time we talked in
the fall you are mainly doing data
collection and analysis if you begin to
look at the control piece where do you
stand with your wireless sensor network
project yeah it's a question for anyone
out here yeah anyone
we'll be able to test ember
we were a little bit sort of constrained
out later on what we're doing to that
but this is Stephanie interesting
that's the next step our data is facing
little bit more challenge right now
testing in terms of neighborhood park
island
store that data for
move our focus
a little bit more into the data
compression David storage cart
but this control stuff
points
at the said we want to take a joint
computing and physical control approach
that's that sort of based investment but
if your workload changes how to
consolidate the workload that can make
like your facility psychically sign life
easier
apartment dynamically control of who's I
what's gonna work out
so we're investigating things
load-balancing shut down shins and opens
at the
recording factor into that
that's right here we go
you know we're talking with a client to
about pulling a lot more data both ite
data as well as you know as I mentioned
the the server temperature data and how
do you actually do control based on
utilization of your CPU and a server and
and some of those features I think we'd
all love to be there are the challenges
for a lot of customers for IT and
facilities are still kind of two
different worlds so yeah it sounds like
the the data the amount of data you're
collecting has been kind of a unexpected
unexpected gotcha that you've kind of
figured out any other challenges or any
kind of big insights that you guys have
seen from your experience what's gone as
expected fair enough fair enough ok ok
uh yeah this is sales guide through this
in by Don yeah so hopefully I gave you a
little bit of idea i mean we're using
wireless mesh networking technology its
kind of off the shelf but i think the
real step forward we've taken is with
the control piece and having the dynamic
control you know i think the interesting
part is this this really works well with
other best practices out there you know
for example hot aisle a cold aisle
containment we've done that with some
clients and they're able to get some
great results because as you contain
your your environments you know the
responses and the changes in those
environments become a little bit more
critical so having the good sensing data
in there adds a lot of value to your
control strategy so and as I'm sure
you've seen the installation of these
wireless sensors is pretty non-obtrusive
to the operations to the facility so
that's that's about all I have if you
guys have any more questions or so
work in this industry where does see the
next big challenge
which is we have the wonderful solution
and everybody hugs and use it some
challenges yeah yeah so I of course we'd
love to have everybody out there with
data centers use our solution you know
we just we're all in business to make
money but I think we've touched on to
really large challenges here I mean you
the predictive control that you
mentioned you know at you can begin to
especially owner-occupied data center so
like Microsoft's or Yahoo's or IBM's or
some of those type of people where they
have kind of a standard a little bit
more predictability in their IT load you
know being able to do some predictive
control it's a little harder in colo
facilities but still applicable I think
that the probably the more pressing
challenge is merging this world of IT
and facilities getting cpu utilization
data getting hard drive utilization data
and pulling that all in to the
facilities people getting them to talk
so you can provide you know you guys
have I know Microsoft has done a good
job it's and you know some of the
dashboards around data center
utilization most customers aren't there
you guys are definitely on the forefront
of that to really pull to get the IT and
facilities people seeing the same
information making decisions off the
same information as well as then driving
the control piece of it too we would
love to get to the point where you know
the facilities control can talk to your
vm installations and coordinate you know
where VM instances run both with
physically within a data center between
data centers you know based on the going
power rate in an area or capacity I
think there's some big opportunities
there but all those challenges really
are go down to how do facilities and IT
people work together and it becomes a
little bit of a cultural thing within
companies of how you align these two
organizations so that they work together
I yeah and the other big piece is that a
lot of data centers out there are very
old think over half the data centers or
over five years old in the US and you
know there's it so how do you retrofit
your existing data centers because
building a new day centre is easily a
thousand dollars a square foot to build
out so we see the the financial
challenges at least no shorts are quite
large for a lot of our customers so yeah
but with the data that you collect you
store most of it for long-term view sir
every night right now you sit for right
now or at least the two example you gave
her kind of smaller right yeah we're not
running to the amount of you yeah and is
it just it right now you're just running
on smaller data centers or do you do
something with that DNA either get you
know get rid of it or right so just and
this is my assumption is that we don't
have as Center rich of an environment as
your deployments here my guess is you
put a lot more sensors are you doing
like a sensor per rack I'm not sure what
level of data you're collecting but we
don't collect quite as much data to do
the control within the data center so
given you no hard drive capacities we
don't see a big problem in the
foreseeable future you know with
installations even up to you know 102
and 1,000 square feet so I think the
simple answer is we haven't hit that
issue at this point but what we
typically see long-term is that a lot
more of the data around fan energy is a
little bit more pertinent to keep over
the long term especially as customers
trend their energy usage some of the
temperature data you know probably can
be compressed into you know 15 or
20-minute intervals over time you know
for anything that's over a couple years
old so the
at this point yeah but at this point we
save all the data and and don't run into
capacity issues at this point any crowd
watches uh so I think one of the
interesting pieces is that where you
actually position the sensors is pretty
important I'm not sure if you've run
into this but yeah but even across one
rack you know typical volume server you
know temperature between the sides and
the middle and in the site there can be
a 425 degree temperature difference so
you know it's it's interesting as as we
begin to work with more more customers
that positioning of the centers as
important as I've talked about with the
doors you know by putting on the outside
of the door versus inside the door you
can we've seen up to 19 degree
temperature differences so that that's
kind of a gotcha is that you need to be
a little bit careful of exactly where
you place the sensor on a rack one other
piece so we've had some data centers
where you know we have these variable
frequency drives that people will go
around and turn them up and just you
know as they're walking through the data
center and some like an hour d facility
for a large customer that we have
there's just a guy likes to turn them up
because he wants to make sure what
server is cool so you know there's some
cultural things to around when you walk
into data center you know most people
you've seen the you know heavy coat
sitting right outside and they want
their data center cold and you know I
know like Christian bellotti is a big
proponent of running your data centers
as hot as possible so I think they're
some of the gotchas around understanding
the culture of the data center and the
users and your customer so what control
right
go to water loss what kind of
transistors you see a big spike when you
turn something off and then graduate and
settle or ice moves to worry about the
the short term big big changes
yeah no it's a good question I know it
in the the system can adapt and also
just like any control mechanism there
are some tuning parameters of how
quickly the system responds you know
it's as some PID loops built-in if you
guys are control engineers you know so a
little bit of it kind of depends on the
particular customer so some of that is
configurable we have a unit we have a
pretty good set of kind of base
parameters but one of the service we as
a company offer a service to you know do
a bunch of analysis on their data on say
a monthly basis that we can recommend
you know some fine tuning and making
sure your system runs as well as
possible so yeah we have done you know
some minor adjustments with the control
piece specifically when the system turns
on yeah typically we see a drop in fan
speed some customers it's pretty
constant typically we'll see daily
fluctuations like I said you know one
customer 730 you know it'll be right
ants minimum at fifty percent and then
it'll start fluctuating between fifty
and sixty percent over the day and and
then go down at the end of the day just
based on usage it just to jump back to
one of the challenges that I just
remember it is so there's fans and all
these computers right there most of them
now our variable speed and I think what
challenge for all of us is that we can
control you know the cooling units but
if we ramped up temperatures too high
then the fans on these servers will kick
on and they're incredibly inefficient
cuz they're really small so they can
actually negate a lot of the energy
usage that you might be saving in your
larger units you know this again this
example of a 15-degree difference in the
door you'd open up the door and you'd
hear the fans and the server's ramp down
so I think a challenge again as we can
pull more information out of the IT
systems is making sure we look at a
holistic perspective of cooling both
from your cracks as well as your fans
and your servers so I think that's
another interesting part yep
was that you gave it seemed like this
since there's more very it's like you
didn't correct you to proving that very
dense but you talked about you know
getting that temperature sensors from
the motherboards and whatnot which
obviously would be orders of maggots
Morgan yes so do you think you'll be
able to use that data efficiently and
actually get it further improvements
from from additional data or is there
some point we're getting more data and
won't actually help you become an FeO
it's more data but it's not going to
have right so it's a great question
what's interesting is the way we've
built our software we can support you
know as much data as you can as you can
get and we will try to extract the most
information I think implementations were
really tell if there's you know that
much more information to learn from the
data coming out of servers particular
density you did on those examples or
like I guess do you have some intuition
where that data doesn't help you you
know I'm not to justify
right so I to be frank the decision of
round number of sensors is as much
control as an economic decision it
sensors cost money and you know there's
certain point of each customer as a
certain budget so you know we have some
intuition about you know placing the
sensors with an appropriate density to
really understand thermal dynamic
environment of your data center as as
well as you know the densities to make
sure your costs stay low and get an
appropriate return with taking
temperatures from servers your marginal
cost of an additional temperature point
is incredibly small and so we think we
get a lot more value out of that you
know they're the this the number of
points I think we'll actually be
necessary to because what we've seen is
the temperature probes in the servers
are pretty cheap and relatively
inaccurate so you know from a
statistical perspective if you know rack
is what 42 you and if you have 42
servers in there you can you can do some
statistical analysis you know around the
law of large numbers if you have over 30
30 points roughly you'll be able to get
a better estimate of what the
temperatures are so when you go to
measuring server temperatures having
that data will be important because a
lot of that will be filtered out anyway
because of you know bad sensors or you
know rogue points or will you use them
in inject I think the simple answer is
time will tell we'll always have a
system to be able to do it both ways
we've had a couple clients particular
telcos that won't do wireless and their
data centers especially anything with a
911 switch they don't allow you with
cell phones in there so there are some
environments that tend to well that
won't do wireless so there are also some
points that that are hard to monitor so
we actually typically put a sensor on
the crack units measure return and
supplier because the sensors in these
Libra units are notoriously poor
so a wireless sensor there is the only
way to get better accurate data so I'm
sure it'll probably be a heterogeneous
environment at least in the short term
yeah all right good thank you yep